on va revenir au National on reparlera
du de l'international Michel tout à
l'heure mais hier le Sénat a voté le
texte immigration Steve un texte que la
majorité sénatoriale a clairement durci
oui 5 jours de débat en séance publique
à quoi il faut ajouter la séance d'hier
et le vote solennel sur l'ensemble du
texte alors il y a plusieurs grandes
mesures effectivement qui ont été
ajoutées par le Sénat on va aller voir
il y a la création de quotas pour
l'immigration économique tous les ans un
débat parlementaire aura lieu pour fixer
le nombre de personnes admises à
séjourné en France les sénateurs aussi
limiter le regroupement familial en
durcissant les conditions du dispositif
ils ont également supprimé pour les
étrangers en situation irrégulière
l'aide médicale d'État remplacé par une
Amu n médicale d'urgence ils ont
supprimé l'article 3 le fameux article 3
sur la régularisation des sanspapier
dans les métiers en tension après un
deal entre les LR et Union centriste
cette régularisation se fera au cas par
cas de façon exceptionnelle après feu
vert des préfets le Sénat rétablit le
délit de séjour irrégulier supprimé par
François Hollande et qui sanctionne la
prè présence sur le territoire d'une
personne en situation irrégulière la
chambre haute a également levé les
protections qui pèsent sur certains
étrangers afin de pouvoir expulser plus
facilement ceux qui représentent une
menace pour l'ordre public et toutes ces
mesures alors qui est pour qui est
contre un scrutin public était organisé
ce qui veut dire qu'on connait le vote
de chaque sénateur sans surprise pour la
gauche c'est un très grand nonom on va
écouter nos discussions n'ont pas été à
la hauteur du sujet la réalité des flux
migratoires croissants et les solutions
ind
pour intégrer les étrangers qui
continueront à arriver malgré les
barrières qu'on peut mettre
administrativ ou physi devraitê à la
base de toutes le réflexion de toutes le
décision de toutes le décision
législativ non seulement ce projet de
loi tel qu'issu de notre discussion ne
nous a pas permis d'avancer sur ce sujet
mais il a très largement empiré la
situation des étrangers qui vivent sur
notre sol an
aprèsintération totalement disparu du
texte à l'instar du ministre du Travail
qui n'est toujours pas là aujourd'hui
qui a déserté les débats résultat il ne
s'agit plus que d'être méchant avec les
gentils et avec tous les autres ce qu'on
a pu remarquer aussi c'est l'offensive
du groupe macroniste RDPI qui a voté
majoritairement pour le texte mais qui a
tiré à boulet rouge sur certaines
mesures comme sur la suppression de
l'Ame écoutez nous espérons que
l'Assemblée nationale reviendra sur ce
qui représente à nos yeux une faute
morale et une erreur grave en matière de
santé
publique pas de surprise en ce qui
concerne la majorité sénatoriale
puisqu'on votait très clairement pour
son texte celui qu'elle a contribué à
largement durcir François Noë buffet
président de la commission des lois n
pas manqué de le rappeler nous avons
souhaité fixer cette politique
migratoire dans le texte clairement de
manière à ce que les choses soient
parfaitement clair pour tout le monde
j'allais dire et que les mesures qui en
découlent soient parfaitement cohér
érente le Sénat a largement travaillé
largement contribué probablement modifié
une grande partie de ce texte là pour
répondre à la proposition que nous avons
faite qui est celle d'un texte et d'une
stratégie clairement établie adoption du
projet de loi à 210 voix pour 115
comptes sur 325 suffrages exprimés il
contenait 27 articles au total au moment
de son arrivée au Sénat il repart d'ici
avec environ 90 articles reste à savoir
ce qu'il en restera après l'examen des
députés et on suivra évidemment tout ça
Michel les qui ont donc voté un texte à
leur mains considérablement durci est-ce
que c'est une victoire pour la droite au
Sénat je l'avaveis dit c'est une
victoire pour la droite au Sénat mais
c'est fini ça va passer maintenant au
Parlement et et ça sera une autre paire
de manche un autre une autre séquence
qui va éver un autre enjeu pour
l'exécutif bien évidemment très
certainement il y aura le c'est la
raison pour laquelle les macronist ici
au Sénat se sont positionnés ainsi il y
aura une attitude du groupe majoritaire
pour détricoter les mesures les plus
dures euh l'épreuve de force commencera
à ce moment-là entre l'exécutif et euh
et et le groupe majoritaire et
l'ensemble de la de l'assemblée et on
verra dans quelle mesure effectivement
le l'enjeu principal c'est-à-dire de
faire passer cette loi sans le
493 qui est un un enjeu majeur pour
Gérard daranin beaucoup plus que pour
éisabeth ban d'ailleurs euh donc sera
avéré donc la droite a gagné une
première bataille est loin d'avoir gagné
la guerre oui voilà c'est très bien
résumé on est dans le jeu Jeu de rôle
classique qui est plus clair la victoire
de la droite cette première victoire
cette première étape est plus claire que
pour la réforme des retraites c'est que
maintenant l'assemblée va s'ans doute
détricôé j'entendais les réactions de
plusieurs sénateurs issus de la gauche
il faut le dire par rapport aux enquêtes
d'opinion tes que nous restitue les
sympathisants de gauche comme la manière
dont il parle de ce projet de loi
immigration une partie des élus de
gauche sont quand même en décalage avec
le peuple de gauche puisque les
sympathisants de gauche étaient plutôt
favorable à la suppression de l'aide
médicale d'État c'est une sorte de totem
de chiffon rouge qui était circonscrit à
une époque à la droite à la droite
extrême et qui est maintenant sa
suppression fait l'objet d'un consensus
auprès de l'ensemble des Français idem
pour le regroupement familial le seul
point où le le durcissement du projet
par les sénateurs étant yatus avec ce
que nous disent les Français c'est sur
la régularisation des sansapi on avait
parlé ici pour les métiers ention où on
est en gros à de tiers des Français
favorables parce que les Français voient
dans leur vie quotidienne la pénurie
d'emploi ce qui explique aussi le fait
que le chômage est disparu ce soit
évaporé du spectre de leur principale
préoccupation ouais là est-ce que le
parce qu'icici Gérald Haran devait
trouver un accord avec la droite là
l'assemblée c'est avec sa propre
majorité qu'il va devoir composer oui
c'est d'abord effectivement toujours
avec avec la droite certaine manière
pour voilà les amener quand même à
effectivement à à prendre ce texte s'
n'est pas trop détricoté mais c'est
surtout je pense effectivement la grande
explication entre général d'armanin et
la la Major majorité présidentielle et
la famille macroniste qui au fond et
c'est un peu le sentiment qu'on les
darmanist si je puux dire ne les
acceptent pas ça va être le moment on va
dire peut-être crucial le point d'org de
cette de de ces deux quinena et de de
cette présence je dirais de jardamanan
au sein de la macronie ça ça va être à
ce moment-là moment un moment crucial et
c'est vrai que une fois les concérations
je dirait tactiques que l'on a évoqué au
Sénat sont sont sont sont évoqué et bien
ce qui s'est passé aussi Sénat et
Frédéric Le le le restitue bien c'est
aussi un je dirais un un un dessin un
restitué de l'évolution sociologique
française qui envoie des signaux qui
permettront peut-être de comprendre les
évolutions dans les scrutins à venir
notamment ce qui concerne ce sujet de de
l'immigration oui un petit point la
manière dont Michel parle du défi que
doit relever Gérald d'manin convaincre
les députés la majorité macroniste
rappelle furieusement
8 ans après le défi que s'était posé le
jeune ministre Emmanuel Macron censé qui
avait chercher et qui avait plutôt
réussi même si le car93 lui avait
empêché de se
compter convaincre la majorité
socialiste de l'époque sur sa fameuse
loi de simplification la loi Macron
c'est 8 ans après on peut faire une
sorte d'homotéie entre le Macron de 2015
face à la face à la majorité socialiste
lui-même n'étant pas socialiste et le
général manin issu de LR auprès duquel
il conserve une côte de popularité très
forte un l'image du trait n'a jamais si
je puux dire c'est jamais installé
auprès des sympathisants de droite qui
doit lui chérald dermanin convaincre
même si voilà le le coup près du 493
pourrait créer chez lui une frustration
et pourquoi pas une une aventure
solitaire une aventure présidentielle
enfin voilà on peut en tirant le fil
créer une sorte de récit paralal en tout
cas une aventure solitaire qui a dans et
déjà un peu comme
parce que on est après effectivement le
fait queisabeth Bor été confirmée au
gouvernement ce qui pour geréralin a été
un moment difficile à passer puisque
c'est un secret pour personne il aurait
bien aimé être n matigon en en étant pas
n matigon il s'aperçoit effectivement il
prend conscience qu'Emmanuel Macron ne
veut pas l'intégrer dans son premier
cercle et c'est là effectivement que
comment c'est le début en tout cas on
pourra dater je sais pas ce qu'elle
donnera on pourra dater le moment de
cette démarche émancipatrice euh à
partir de ce moment-là et on verra dans
quelle mesure le texte immigration lui
permettra d'avancer d'accélérer ou d'en
être arrêté mais est-ce que
politiquement il att tant que ça à perd
gerérald haranin utiliser un 493 alors
que les Français soutiennent ce texte on
n'est pas dans la même situation que
lors de la réforme des retraitees où ça
avait été vécu comme un passage en force
le 493 est devenu maintenant le symbole
du passage en force et de l'échec d'une
capacité à pouvoir rassembler et à
pouvoir faire passer donc un texte à
l'Assemblée encore plus paradoxalement
dans le contexte de la majorité relative
et dans le contexte dans lequel se
trouve donc l'exécutif Emmanuel Macron
donc aujourd'hui réussir à faire passer
un texte
1493 c'est le symbole d'une réussite
même si quand on fait passer 493 on
réussit quand même parce que c'est ça
reste dans dans dans dans dans la dans
la législation mais il a il y a
maintenant un statut un statut de de
voilà de de de décret de l'outil
d'urgence qui vient palier une
incapacité à pouvoir convaincre et c'est
pour ça qu'il a absolument intérêt à ne
pas avoir de 493 oui le 493 n'est plus
vu comme un outil facilitant le travail
d'un gouvernement Michel Rocard 28 fois
entre 88 et 91 même situation de
majorité relative là clairement pour les
Français on l'a bien vu ça commandc
vraiment au moment de l'utilisation du
recours par Manuel Vals lors de la loi
travail et même lors de la loi Macron le
493 est vu comme une sorte d'attentat
démocratique et vu comme une sorte
d'atteinte aux libertés et de pass en
force d'autoritarise et donc réussir à
passer un projet de loi 1493 peut être
synonyme de brevet ou de tableau
d'honneur de négociateur de de
manœuvriers habilees pour le ministre de
l'intérieur c'est d'ailleurs juste assez
savoureux d'entendre en général Macron
maintenant défendre le 493 alors que il
était il avait poussé des cris d'or
frais quand il avait été atteint et
touché par le 493 de Manuel Vals on va
parler de votre baromètre du coup on va
continuer à parler d'Emmanuel Macron de
Gérald daranin le baromètre des
personnalités
Frédéric on va voir les C premiers c'est
édard Philippe qui est toujours en tête
sur le podium suivi de Gabriel at et
Bruno le oui c'est un baromètre Fiducial
pour match et SUD RADIO qui est baissier
ce mois-ci puisqu a 31 baisses sur 50
faut pas oublier que la défiance demeure
j'ai envie de dire malheureusement la
première grille de lecture des Français
vis-à-vis des des politiques d'où le
mérite des trois premiers d'être
parfaitement stable par rapport au mois
précédent et ce qui est intéressant ce
qui est intéressant si on s'intéresse si
on regarde ce baromètre de 50
personnalités à travers le prisme des
trois blocs le bloc Ren le bloc nupes la
nupes très malade on le sait et le bloc
central et ben c'est intéressant de voir
que dans le bloc central il y a cinq
personnalités parmi les 10 premiers
éedouard Philippe gabrielal le maire
François baayerou et Olivier verrand qui
est le ministre qui est qui progresse le
plus avec avec Monsieur Dupont moréti
malgré sa mise en cause de la Cour de
Justice de la République qu parmi les C
premiers tout à fait qu premers et C
parmi et six pardon parmi les 10
premiers dans à contrar parallèlement
Emmanuel Macron petit à petit renoue un
lien avec les Français c'estes quatre
points de gagnés depuis maintenant 2
mois et il faut toujours regarder la
question qui a été poser bonne mauvaise
opinion c'est pas une question qui qui
mobilise l'action c'est plus l'image la
personnalité et le fait qu'il arrive à
40 % c'est plutôt intéressant pour lui
avec un rétablissement dans ses segments
tradition électoraux les personnes âgées
les cadres supérieurs et les
sympathisants Renaissance et LR face à
ce bloc central les autres personnalités
du bloc RN et surtout du bloc de gauche
ne sont pas autant à la fête prenons un
chiffre je Mélenchon pour la première
fois passe sous la barre des 30 % 29 %
de bonnes opinions et il paye ces Herm
ses déclarations ses propos filtrant
avec l'antisémitisme et ce qui est très
fort c'est pour lui désormais une
rupture à gauche puisque il n'est
maintenant que la 7e ou 8e personnalité
de gauche et il perd je crois 8 à 9
points dans son socle électoral on on va
en parler de la gauche mais un mot sur
Emmanuel Macron parce que Michel tout à
l'heure parlait de la situation
internationale est-ce que ça joue dans
sa côte de popularité son positionnement
sur la guerre Israël oui ça a joué
puisqu'il y a eu un petit rebond ce
mois-ci ça a joué dans un contexte il
faut le dire dégradé pour lui
traditionnellement quand les Français ne
s'intéressaient pas énormément aux
questions international on avait une
bienveillance à priori pour tous les
présidents en fait les 20 ans de ce
baromètre ifob Fiducial match Paris
Match et SUD RADIO on avait des
présidents impopulaires mais qui étaient
très bien notés sur l'international le
Jacques Chirac de 2005 2007 rapporté
beaucoup de contrat à l'étranger c'était
très positif pour Nicolas Sarkozi et
même très fortement pour François
Holland manuel Macron dans dans
l'enquête du mois dernier il il a vu 60
% de Français M content de sa capacité à
à défendre l'intérêt de la France à
l'étranger donc son voyage en Israël lui
a permis de rétablir un peu les choses
mais effectivement sur son image il y a
un petit mieux comme s'il y avait ce
mouvement de décrispation après cette
séquence retraite qui a été terrible
pour lui en 2023 unequel oui son enjeu
reste effectivement de pouvoir montrer
qu'il est capable de pouvoir défendre
les intérêts c'est vrai que très
certainement le le le multidynamisme de
du président sur beaucoup de sujets en
ce moment passant effectivement de la
sphère internationale aux inondations
dans le Nord doit aussi montrer voilà
qu'il y a cette cette cette existence on
sent bien que c'est aussi certainement
le résultat de cette activité euh voir
voilà sur activité qu'il a développé
depuis quelques temps on étant sur
beaucoup de champs en même temps euh ce
qui donne le sentiment d'être un
président dynamique qui est décorrélé de
l'efficacité de de de la démarche mais
en tout cas euh en tout cas il y a
effectivement cette démarche cette cette
image de président dynamique et qui
bouge un petit mot sur la gauche ce que
vous parliez de la baisse de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et alors ce qui est marquant
c'est qu'il y a un écart énorme entre
Fabien Roussel et Jean-Luc Mélenchon
dans le bar oui c'est vrai quand on
regarde les 10 premiers on a deux
personnalités de gauche qui sont des
personnalités antiupes anti Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Fabien Roussel vous le disiez
qui est comme le mois précédent premier
à à gauche avec prers et dans les cinq
premiers on parle quand même du leader
du Parti communiste français hein c'est
c'est c'est quand même assez inédit et
puis François Hollande qui malgré une
baisse est nettement devant par rapport
à Jean-Luc Mélenchon oui c'est vrai que
les les personnalités de nupes sont
toutes à la baisse y compris François
Ruffin qui paye peut-être un
positionnement ambigu critique vis-à-vis
de Jean-Luc mélonchon notamment sur la
question d'Israël mais sans franchir le
pas d'une véritable rupture oui pour
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est la personnalité
après Éric zébour qui est le plus rejeté
euh des Français avec un socle de très
mauvaises opinions il faut toujours voir
Orian les baromètres à travers les PUL
de soutien les plus forts les
excellentes opinions et les très
mauvaises c'est lui qui a un des socles
les plus bas on voit très bien comment
sur cette séquence il paye l'addition et
on a tendance à faire un parallèle avec
la fameuse séquence de 2018 la
perquisition la République c'est moi il
n'avait pas perdu à gauche autant qu'il
n'a perdu maintenant c'est vrai que là
sur toute une série de sujets depuis les
aut urbaine depuis l'idée qu'il y a un
racisme systémique depuis que la police
tu depuis la BAA il est en dissonance en
en décalage avec sa majorité de gauche
et avec son sole électoral nickel et
surtout je pense que les Français
perçoivent aussi sur le le l'aspect
autocratique non démocratique du
fonctionnement donc de son parti et
surtout la manière dont il traite les
personnalités qui osent avoir un autre
avis donc de ce point de vue-là on peut
pas dire que que que les Français
souscrivent à à à la à avoir voilà une
dérive un autocrate à leur tête et et à
gauche on s'aperçoit bien que
l'efficacité là aussi n'est pas au
rendez-vous et très certainement on
assistera à des prises de
position de du point de vue des
dissidents deanupes alors Emmanuel
Macron qui voulait qui veut réunir les
chefs de parti majorité et opposition
après-demain à SaintDenis mais après
Olivier fort Emmanuel bonpard c'est éic
CTI hier le patron desalr qui a annoncé
qu'il n'irait pas on va écouter ce qu'en
pense Gérard Larché le président du
Sénat il était ce matin l'invité de la
matinale de France Inter il y a un ordre
du jour cet ordre du jour comme je
l'avais demandé nous a été envoyé
suffisamment tôt nous parlerons bien sûr
de la situation internationale mais nous
parlerons des questions de référendum de
décentralisation nous parlerons aussi
des outres mires il y a du coup vous
regrettez vous regrettez l'absence d'éic
Coti à cette réunion c'est sa décision
bah c'est votre famille politiqueoui
c'est sa décision je peux en comprendre
les raisons il est dans son rôle de
président de parti de prendre cette
décision elle lui appartient il m'en
avait informé hier matin j'en ai pris
acte voilà Gérard Larcher il en prend
acte il la comprend on n pas
l'impression qu'il a partage vraiment
lui il ira en tout cas à Saint-Denis
c'est quoi ces divisions chez les
républicains bah c'est un je dirais
c'est une une erreur de positionnement
politique parce que dericotti bien sûr
parce que prendre le risque de laisser
Jordan Bardella face à Emmanuel Macron
avec en ce moment les sorts qu'il a et
surtout la manière dont l'Élysée regarde
Jordan Bardella c'est je pense
effectivement un problème politique à
venir on on a bien compris que
effectivement Gérard LCH n'a pas fait
que prendre acte et on peut parfaitement
imaginer que dans le secret de leur
bureau il lui a quand même dit qu'il
commettait une erreur mais il y a aussi
une tension et une pression très forte
au sein de LR de se démarquer de ne plus
donner le sentiment d'aller dans le sens
du président parce que voilà les
échéances approchent les Européennes et
ensuite l'élection présidentielle oui je
noterai quand même que le format
Saint-Denis n'a pas vraiment intéressé
les Français le le premier épisode la
première saison si je peux dire au mois
de septembre avait fait l'objet d'un
niveau de conversation particulièrement
faible pourquoi parce que pour les
Français ça relève de la vie des
organisations partisanes ça ne les
touche pas personnellement même si c'est
vrai que la première parti cette durée
très longue le président qui avait pu
embarquer tout le monde il y avait eu le
sentiment d'une une autre manière de
dialoguer avec les forces politiques
c'est un reproche qui est fait
fréquemment à Emel Macron là c'est vrai
que l'absence de trois principe leader
et préjudiciable mais comme le dit très
bien Michel ça peut aussi être institué
comme un mano à mano Emmanuel Macron
Jordan Parella qui dans le baromètre
Paris Match a un peu payé ses
déclarations minimisant l'antisémitisme
de Jean-Marie Le Pen il ne perd que
trois points ça paraît rien mais auprès
des sympathisants de droite auprès des
sympathisants il perd de mémoire 15
points donc c'était peut-être aussi une
occasion pour Éric soioti d'enfoncer le
clou et de montrer que la vraie droite
c'était lui un dernier mot très
rapidement Michel ça ça veut dire que ça
porte pas forcément préjudice à Emmanuel
Macron cette absence ça veut pas dire
que les rencontres de Saint- fontchit de
fait si si personne en tout cas si des
absents
important sont là bien évidemment ça
altère le processus et ça et ça fera
peut-être ressortir d'autant que les
sujets que que plébiscit les Français ne
sont pas au sujet des conversations
président de la République merci
Frédéric merci Michel on regarde ce qu'
a la une de nos quotidiens régionaux
avant de se
[Musique]
quitter
et à la une de la presse régionale la
visite d'Emmanuel Macron et la
souffrance des habitants du patcalis oui
on a parlait tout à l'heure c'était la
une de la voie du Nord la nation sera à
vos côtés a déclaré le chef de l'État
venu hier à la rencontre des victimes
des inondations Emmanuel Macron a
annoncé des mesures d'urgence et assuré
les sign serit du soutien de l'État sur
la durée 2 semaines maintenant que la
région est soumise à des intempéries
exceptionnelles certains ont absolument
tout perdu et c'est pas terminé puisque
le P decalis affronte depuis hier un
nouvel épisode plus vieux le département
a été replacé en vigilance rouge
inquiétude également à l'Est oui c'est à
la une des quotidiens l'est républicains
de l'Alsace les cours d'eau montent dans
la région des habitants ont même été
évacués de manière préventive dans le
Hain alors que certaines retenu d'eau
menacent de céder des coulés de Bou ont
touché certains villages un mois
maintenant qu'il pleut tous les jours en
en Alsace qui a été placé en vigilance
risque de cru une situation qui frappe
de plein fois les agriculteurs oui on
voir le Courrier Picard la pluie et les
inondation compromettent le travail de
nos agriculteurs notamment la campagne
bettervière les agriculteurs sont en
première ligne car les intempéries
empêchent l'arrachage des betterf tous
les secteurs de la filière sont touchés
dans la région les conditions sont
extrêmes il y a la pluie la boue les les
inondations des terres bref c'est la
galère et si le Paradis se trouvait dans
le Limousin oui 1 € le mètre carré de
terrain si vous voulez acheter une
maison c'est peut-être là-bas qu'il faut
aller c'est ce que nous dit le populaire
du centre pour enrayer le déclin
démographique la commune de sursac a
lancé une opération audacieuse et ça
marche la campagne a été lancée cet été
plus de 1000 personnes de toute la
France ont contacté la mairie il a fallu
procéder à une sélection très rigoureuse
au final 15 familles ont été retenues
elles vont déménager dans les prochaines
semaines ce seront bientôt des
fursquetis je crois qu'on dit comme ça
on vous suit on termine par un mot de
culture oui un Corse qui part à la
conquête de Paris de la France et du
monde ça vous dit quelque chose un petit
peu Napoléon encore ce matin fait sa Une
sur le le film Napoléon de RIDY Scott il
sort la semaine prochaine mais on en
parle déjà beaucoup le journal consacre
trois pages spéciales à cette super
productionou Wen ou voilà c'est frédri
qui va vous aider américaine américaine
l'acteur Jine Phenix qui joue l'empereur
a accordé une interview exclusive à cors
matin c'est àdire aujourd'hui merci
hollywoodien
voilà merci beaucoup merci Frédéric
merci Michel d'avoir été avec nous merci
à tous de nous avoir suivi prochain
rendez-vous à 15h la séance de question
d'actualité au Gouvernement au Sénat et
à 18h Thomas H sens public très bonne
journée à
demain